attention j'en entends un qui arrive bon
axe panique
on vous en montre un autre les premiers
surfeurs des neiges sont arrivés dans
les vosges il ya une quinzaine d'années
au début on les prenait pour un
extraterrestre avec leurs énormes
planchent aujourd'hui le surf est devenu
un sport à part entière avec de vraies
compétitions et de vrais athlètes
c'est quoi la différence avec le script
by séquenceur faudra les deux hommes
savent aussi en ski on a on a les deux
pieds libre et voilà en deux mois vous
savez presque sous lui attention aux
spurs aussi on est face à l'abri des
gamelles pas au début c'est sûr quand on
sait pas trop en faire ça peut être
dangereux pour les gens qui sont autour
mais quand on arrive avec fera tourner
ça deviens tu as des complexes quand tu
vois les garçons qui skie beaucoup plus
vite non pas trop je me dis que en
continuant j'arriverai à faire pareil
trop modeste florine avec cet autre
alsacien
elle fait quand même partie des 25
meilleurs clubs français dans les vosges
plus de 100 mordus sont déjà inscrits en
compétition on a largement dépassé les
domaines de mode
pourquoi parce que c'est une discipline
qui est relativement facile et on on a
jusque là un public qui essentiellement
d'anciens skieurs où il faut accepter
d'être débutants pendant deux ou trois
jours
et puis ensuite on progresse pas très
vite la preuve en images